To
some extent the answer to the question of
whether some humans are born with tails and
how prevalent it is depends on your definition
of “tail.”
For instance, a variety of things may protrude
from the tailbone of a newborn, including
cysts, tumors and even a parasitic twin.
But very rarely a human is born with an actual
extra appendage that is generally considered
a vestigial tail.
During fetal development, the human embryo
at about the 5th week has a tail that usually
disappears by the 8th week, being absorbed
by the growing embryo.
However, for a rare few, the tail is not absorbed
and persists through birth.
Typically (for those exceptionally few born
with tails), the appendage in question is
comprised of adipose and connective tissue,
bundles of striated muscle and even nerves
and blood vessels.
Noticeably absent from even a vestigial tail,
however, are any sign of vertebrae or controlled
movement.
As for specific examples, in 2012, the paper,
Spectrum of human tails: A report of six cases,
detailing the experience of a handful of patients
with vestigial tails, ranging in age from
3 days to 2 years.
Of the six, four of the tails were situated
in the lumbar area, and, perhaps not surprisingly,
three of the patients had spina bifida (a
congenital defect where the lower part of
the spinal cord is exposed through a hole
in the spine).
One child had a tail protruding from his buttock,
while the last had a protrusion from the sacral
region.
Five of the six had no connection between
their tails and spines, and they underwent
successful surgeries to remove the unwanted
appendages.
The sixth’s parents refused to give consent,
although it is not clear why, and the doctors
in question were not able to follow up with
that child.
Notably, in one of the children, her tail
unusually included bone, as well as cartilage,
fat and neural tissue.